[Musik]
kalle will cannabis fachmann werden in
einem kurs lernt er alles über die
pflanze vom anbau bis zum verkauf um
sich so gut auszukennen dass er
konsumentinnen bestmöglich beraten kann
dafür ist der 27 jährige extra angereist
aus deutschland
ich freue mich auf jeden fall das jetzt
sehen dass ich auch die chance habe die
sachen vor ort zu sehen dass ich nicht
nur theoretisch sachen lernen sondern
dass für ihren zu einer farm fahren wo
das geld herkommt
wir sind im emerald renkl kalifornien
nirgendwo in den usa wird mehr cannabis
angebaut seit sechs jahren ist das hier
ganz legal kalle und die anderen lernen
wie unterschiedliche sorten schmecken
wie sie wirken können am ende müssen sie
eine prüfung ablegen um sich offiziell
cannabis zur lehre nennen zu dürfen
vor der ersten unterrichtseinheit am
morgen gibt es erstmal was zur
entspannung einer der lehrer als 2 er
ist schon seit gut 60 jahren im geschäft
lange bevor cannabis legal war als viele
hier ihre pflanzen noch in den bergen
versteckten immer mit der angst im
gefängnis zu landen
die hürden waren einfach unglaublich und
dass einige leute es geschafft haben die
entschlossenheit hatten durchzuhalten
ihr schuldet uns ein großes dankeschön
[Gelächter]
wenn die hat die summe je schüler innen
hier auf ihre kameras fangen eingeladen
sie ist eine von denen die durchgehalten
hat schon ihre mutter war farmerin heute
wachsen ihre kinder mit den pflanzen auf
meine kinder sind mit cannabis pflanzen
im vorgarten aufgewachsen hier wachsen
herbst dort wächst cannabis einfach eine
weitere pflanze ich würde meine kinder
lieber kann er bis als tabakrauchen
lassen oder als crack oder andere
bringen
für kleine cannabis farmen bringt die
legalisierung auch hörten mehr
staatliche regulierung höhere steuern
wenn die kennt das problem nur zu gut
für viele lohnt sich der legale an
die illegal betreiber verkaufen ihr zeug
nebenbei schwarz zu finanzieren so ihren
legalen betrieb sie können sich die
steuern und vorschriften sonst nicht
leisten es ist ein chaos es ist ein
wirklich großes chaos in kalifornien
wer sich aufs cannabis geschäft einlässt
brauche herzblut auch dass eine
botschaft des zum eeg kurses
ermitteln er spüren wann die beste zeit
für die ernte ist das ist teil des
unterrichts zwar hört seinen pflanzen
sogar ganz genau zu
die pflanze soll mir sagen wann sie
geerntet werden möchte ich gehe also
pflanze und frage bist du bereit morgen
rein zu kommen nein möchtest du gerne
schon rein kommen
nach der ernte wird aus cannabis bzw
hans marihuana als marihuana
beziehungsweise gras bezeichnet man die
getrockneten blüten haschisch ist das
harz das aus der cannabispflanze
gewonnen wird es kann auch geraucht
werden ist aber etwas stärker doch
[Musik]
der konsum hat schattenseiten art und
hazel mussten das in der eigenen familie
leben die beiden wohnen in kalifornien
in der nähe von san francisco ihr
jüngster sohn fing an zu kiffen als er
14 war
[Musik]
er litt an depressionen und seine
freunde experimentierten mit alkohol und
marihuana mit der zeit konsumierte er
immer mehr und das wurde ein echtes
problem für ihn
jahrelang versuchten sie verschiedene
therapien gingen sogar zu einem arzt der
mit cannabis behandelt doch sohn kevin
rauchte mehr als gesund für ihn war
er hat so gelitten und war so frustriert
und dann hatte er eine weitere psychose
so sind wir hier gelandet wir haben
unseren sohn verloren
hat sich
das leben genommen die polizei kam
mitten in der nacht und sagte
das letzte was er zu mir sagte war
cannabis hat mein leben ruiniert am ende
hat er erkannt dass es ihm nicht
geholfen hat es hat ihn kränker gemacht
cannabis ist in den usa längst kein
nischenmarkt mehr der handel mit gras
bringt milliarden ein selbst große
firmen wie mal büro in bad weiter sind
eingestiegen etwa 40 millionen menschen
in den usa regelmäßig
das land ist ein flickenteppich in 18
staaten ist der konsum legal doch längst
nicht überall darf cannabis auch
verkauft werden zum beispiel in der
hauptstadt washington dc für unternehmer
magna gibt für das zu einer absurden
situation um legal zu bleiben darf er
cannabis nur verschenken nicht verkaufen
für seinen online shop pink fox nutzt er
diese gesetzeslücke aus die com domain
wenn sie bei mir etwas kaufen geben wir
ihnen gerne cannabis dazu solange sie 21
jahre oder älter sind wenn sie eine
mütze oder ein hemd oder einen pullover
kaufen einfach nur eine maske oder ein
sportbeutel ein paar socken dann haben
sie anspruch auf cannabis
das geschäftsmodell funktioniert hat
aber auch nachteile
er zahlt hohe steuern muss umwege gehen
um sein gras an den konsumenten die
konsumenten zu bringen
[Musik]
diese produkte verkaufen zu müssen wenn
man gleichzeitig genau weiß dass die
kunden eigentlich cannabis wollen ich
würde nicht sagen dass es absurd ist
aber es ist definitiv
zu max repertoire gehören auch hasch
brownies er verpackt nur selbst
angebautes cannabis und bietet so was
auf dem schwarzmarkt nicht garantiert
ist reines gras ohne chemikalien
ladenverkauf gibt es bei ihm nicht ein
stammkunde meldet sich etwa per sms mark
packt ein paar produkte zusammen sie
treffen sich am vereinbarten ort
konnte taylor hat längst genügend
pullover und t-shirts aber über einen
sportbeutel freut er sich immer noch und
bleibt mag auch aus anderen gründen treu
es fühlt sich sicherer anwalt ist legal
ist ich kann nicht für andere sprechen
aber ich versuche ich an die gesetze zu
halten auch wenn ich die sachen woanders
einfacher kaufen könnte wäre mir das
unangenehm weil ich wüsste dass das
illegal ist
ein paar straßen weiter bei kind volk
gibt es nur medizinisches cannabis
besitzer korriban at kommt aus der
finanz branche er wollte geld verdienen
und gleichzeitig etwas gutes tun so sagt
er hat dafür gekämpft dass cannabis
zumindest entkriminalisiert der besitz
nicht mehr bestraft wird
die gegenseite stellte star als würde
man marihuana erst in die gemeinden
bringen wenn man es entkriminalisiert
aber marihuana hat die gemeinden nie
verlassen oder marihuana ist in unserer
gesellschaft weit verbreitet egal ob
illegal oder legal
als der besitz von cannabis in
washington schließlich erlaubt wurde war
das auch eine art anti rassismus
strategien
cannabis wurde früher benutzt um eine
übertriebene polizeipräsenz in schwarzen
vierteln zu rechtfertigen es wurde als
werkzeug verwendet um afroamerikaner
einzusperren
afroamerikaner und auch unsere latino
brüder und schwestern wurden sechs bis
achtmal häufiger verhaftet angeklagt und
eingesperrt als weiße ein unfaires spiel
[Musik]
doch nicht alles ist heute gerechter von
dem cannabis geschäft profitieren vor
allem weiße unternehmer/innen
georgi ich bin der einzige schwarze in
washington dc der eine lizenz für anbau
und herstellung von cannabis hat wir
hoffen dass wir bald eine veränderung
veränderung darum geht es auch die
skicrosser doch er hat einen ganz
anderen weg gewählt will konsumentinnen
zeigen wie sie cannabis pflanzen zuhause
anbauen
[Musik]
ich bringe den leuten bei wie man die
pflanzen ökologisch korrekt anbaut zur
selbstversorgung was sie hier sehen sind
ungefähr fünf und kann als wenn ihre
freunde und familie also kann er bis zum
preis von 100 bis 200 dollar pro woche
verbrauchen dann haben sie hier mit
einer nachhaltigen vorrat
er bietet workshops an und bildet
lehrlinge aus sechs pflanzen darf jede
person an pflanzen das ist in washington
erlaubt die cs broker selbst hat nun ja
ein paar mehr er will deshalb nicht dass
wir zeigen wo er wohnt auch wenn in
privatwohnungen kaum kontrolliert wird
wie man richtig raucht diesen ratschlag
gibt es bei ihm kostenlos dazu
anders als in europa geben wir keinen
tabak dazu rauch wenigstens pures grassi
ich mache mich über niemanden lustig nur
weil er einen joint mit tabak raucht
aber tust du auch wasser in einen
schnaps
die cs broker wartet nun darauf dass
cannabis in washington voll egal wird
und sein geschäftsmodell auch
barth und hese sind gegen die
legalisierung auch wenn sie hier in
kalifornien längst realität ist
mit der legalisierung von cannabis lässt
sich zu viel geld verdienen der einzige
weg profit zu machen besteht darin leute
süchtig zu machen
das tun sie indem sie die kinder früh
daran gewöhnen mit süßigkeiten und
waiting dann werden die kinder süchtig
und sie werden kunden fürs leben es sei
denn sie kommen irgendwann davon los
um den eigenen verlust zu verarbeiten
hilft der kontakt mit anderen
betroffenen
so lernt bad auch mal kennen der anonym
bleiben will er fing im college an zu
kiffen regelmäßig und in großen mengen
[Musik]
ich hatte gedächtnisproblemen ich musste
immer husten mein kopf war nicht klar
wenn ich heim dachte ich dass ich
großartige ideen hätte aber ich habe
nichts davon umgesetzt
irgendwann wurde mir bewusst dass ich
ein serum produktives leben führen
irgendwann wurde mir klar dass er nicht
nur sich selbst schadet sondern auch den
menschen um ihn herum sogar seiner
kleinen tochter
ich fuhr auto meiner frau saß auf dem
beifahrersitz meine tochter in ihrem
kindersitz sie war noch nicht mal ein
jahr alt ich habe die joints an meine
frau weitergereicht so dass meine
tochter sicherlich passiv mit geraucht
hat
mir war plötzlich bewusst dass an diesem
bild etwas sehr falsch ist
mit hilfe von marihuana anonymous
gelingt es mag schließlich aufzuhören
einer gruppe ähnlich der anonymen
alkoholiker
vor 34 jahren rauchte er seinen letzten
job
bat ist mitglied einer solchen gruppe
für angehörige
viele dort haben erlebt wie ihre söhne
und töchter aus der bahn geworfen wurden
cannabis hat risiken da sind sich auch
expertinnen einig aber
die risiken des cannabiskonsums sind im
vergleich zu vielen substanzen die
bereits auf dem markt sind ziemlich
harmlos cannabis ist eine gewohnheit
bildende substanz in manchen fällen
können sie wenn sie eine vorgeschichte
von psychischen erkrankungen haben eine
verschlimmerung dieser psychischen
symptome erfasst
in kalifornien ist dieser zug ohnehin
längst abgefahren es gibt jobs an jeder
ecke cannabis ist teil einer kultur
[Musik]
waren
so tief verankert dass sogar fachleute
ausgebildet werden die bei konsum
beraten die angehenden cannabis summe
lehre lernen genau hinzuschauen
organische verbindungen zu erkennen mit
all ihren sinnen sie bestimmen so die
qualität unterschiedlicher sorten
[Musik]
ich möchte in der lage seien menschen
mit dem cannabis zusammenzubringen was
sie am meisten mögen damit sie mit dem
was sie konsumieren zufrieden sind egal
wie viel sie dafür bezahlt haben
dazu gehört auch die wirkung zu kennen
ob eine sorte besser zum relaxen
geeignet ist oder zum aufputschen für
jeden kunden jede kundin die richtige
empfehlung
cannabis unterscheidet sich von anderen
substanzen weil jeder joint oder jede
sorte eine andere psychologische wirkung
hat einige von ihnen bringen einen zum
kichern nicht wahr diese hier scheint
aus irgendeinem grund nicht zum kichern
anzuregen
der unterschied zum wein summe je
ausspucken gilt nicht
durchaus ziemlich viel seite hier bist
und viele verschiedene sorten
zeit ja ich versuche so viele wie
möglich auszuprobieren
das viele üben zahlt sich aus halle
besteht seine prüfung darf sich
offiziell cannabis zum medien jetzt will
er sein fachwissen nutzen ganz legal und
am liebsten in deutschland
[Musik]